hello and welcome to the program we
begin with some breaking news out of
Iraq where the Supreme Court has ruled
it does not have the Constitutional
authority to dissolve parliament saying
that it must dissolve itself politicians
allied with the influential share leader
mukhtar al-sara had refiled a petition
last month after previous request was
rejected
supporters have been protesting for
months now calling for a complete
overhaul of the political system as well
as new elections now let's go straight
to Imran Khan who's in Baghdad for us
Imran how do we interpret what the
Supreme Court has ruled
okay
well there's one way of interpreting it
which is it is an actual rebuke to the
parliament let me just read you the
summary of the federal Court's decision
the House of Representatives has
exceeded the Constitutional terms and
its penalty is dissolution dissolving
the parliament is not within the powers
of the federal court so the federal
court in that last line have said it's
not down to us we can't do it but it is
a rebuke of the way Parliament has
behaved uh section one of the ruling
says the members of the House of
Representatives after being elected do
not represent themselves all their
political blocks but rather the people
therefore it was necessary for them to
work to achieve what they were elected
for which is the people's interest not
to be a reason to obstruct their
interests and threaten their safety and
the safety of people completely it's a
very strongly worded statement it's
effectively saying to Parliament this is
your mess you sort it out we don't have
the powers to be able to do this it's
put it back firmly into the parliament's
hands that's going to cause another
crisis they're going to be reading this
like we are right now trying to make
sense of it but the only real sense that
anybody I think right now will be able
to make is that yes the Supreme Court
doesn't have the power to dissolve the
uh Parliament but they're also saying
that the parliament isn't acting in the
people's interests and that's an
incredibly strong statement how will it
be received here we won't be expecting
people out on the streets we're going to
be expecting political reactions
cleric a key sheer cleric who has 73
members of parliament uh it's the
largest block he's got a lot to lose
here because he was riding on uh the
federal court dissolving poem because he
wanted to see new elections he'll have a
reaction the tashrin movement of people
that protested in October of 2020 and
had a change of government as a result
they'll have a reaction to this what
that's going to be we don't know had it
just been a normal decision where they
said it's not down to us it's not down
to the Supreme Court and left it at that
it may well have been been easier to
Stage manage but now the Supreme Court
has actually said to the parliament you
guys aren't representing the people and
that needs to be something that
Parliament will and has to react to
okay thank you for that Imran Khan there
for us in Baghdad